كلمه السر السيطره لاجلها تخاض المعارك
لاكثر من شهر في السودان ما زال اشرس
القتال يتركز حول مثلث العاصمه الخرطوم
بحري وام درمان وفي ثلاثه تظل اعين الجيش
والدعم السريع على مواقع استراتيجيه
يرصد مراسلنا بجنوب الخرطوم وقوع اشتباكات
بين قوات الجانبين في الاسلحه الثقيله على
الطريق المؤدي لولايه النيل الابيض
في تطورات القتال الاخرى هزا انفجار وسط
العاصمه السودانيه دون ان تتسنى معرفه
ملابساته ما لا يعرفه احد حتى الان هو مال
هذه المواجهه السودانيه السودانيه التي
امتدت بشكل مقلق غربان تقول مصادر الجزيره
ان مدينه الفاشر مركز اقليم دافور وعاصمه
ولايه شمال دارفور شهد التبادلا كثيفا
لاطلاق النار بين قوات الدعم السريع
والجيش السوداني
وذكرت المصادر ان القوتين تطلقان النار من
مواقع تمركزهما في المدينه ولم تنتشر في
اي مواقع جديده
الى متى القتال يسال عبوم السودانيين منذ
بدءها منتصف الشهر الماضي اوقعت
الاشتباكات المستمره في بلدهم حسب لجنه
اطباء السودان ما لا يقل عن
833 قتيله اما المصابون فهم اكثر من ثلاثه
الاف وثمانمائه
لا تحسب التكلفه البشريه لاي حرب بعدد من
تزهقه من ارواح او تلحقه من اصابات فقط
فمن سلموا من نيران المعارك تطبق عليهم
ماساه انسانيه تتعاظم
تنبه مفوضيه شؤون اللاجئين بالامم المتحده
الا ان القتال الدائره في السودان ادى
لنزوح اكثر من مليون شخص
وتقول المفوضيه انها بحاجه لاربعمائه
وثمانين مليون دولار لحمايه هؤلاء
النازحين ومساعدات المجتمعات التي
تستضيفهم
يجتمع من فرو ومن خلفهم وراءهم على امنيه
واحده هدنه توقف صوت الرصاص
في ذلك الاتجاه تعمل محادثات جده غير
المباشره بين ممثلين عن الجيش السوداني
والدعم السريع هذا مسعا دونه معوقات لكنه
يحاول البناء على اعلان المبادئ الخاص
بحمايه المدنيين وتلبيه الاحتياجات
الانسانيه العاجله